on va voir voler cette rose je dois
retourner là bas tant qu est ce que ceux
ci vous lui obéirez pas alors omura tous
tu ne sois pas responsable de votre mort
de mon père
je m'appelle tél
je suis venu échanger ma vie contre
celle de mon père
[Musique]
je ne sauve à cette heure précise se
devra d'être là
jour et nuit j'attends que vous destinez
mises en situations tellement donné
pourrait combler tous tes désirs vous
croyez qu'une bête comme vous vous
raconter une femme comme moi
que c'est tout de moi
oui ça vous arrange peut-être de ne
jamais penser à votre passé imaginé par
l'oser
bell
si vous ne revenez pas
j'aimerais
annonce moi quelque chose d'excitant
mon fils ne fréquentent pas les crapules
regarde ça vire et chatons abandonnés
tu reviens tu récupères leurs études
trésor
dieu de l'info c'est marthe ont pris 6
juin
[Musique]
est ce que tu as vu
laissez vous aller
[Musique]